We would like to now introduce
a new methodological tool
for analyzing problems that
involve momentum transfers.
And we call that tool
momentum diagrams.
Now, what we'd
like to do is look
at our fundamental idea, which
was, for discrete objects,
we have that-- involved
in a collision-- we have
that the external force
integrated with respect
to time-- in poles-- is equal
to the change in momentum
between two different states.
So this is the momentum
of the final state,
and this is the momentum
of the initial state.
So when we want to
analyze problems,
how can we methodologically
introduce a picture
representation of our problems?
So let's look at what
we need to do first.
We always need to choose a
system that we're referring to.
And with respect to the
choice of that system,
we need to also choose
a reference frame.
Now, once we've done
that, we can now
represent a collision with
respect to this system.
For instance, let's consider
two objects-- as our system
Object 1 and Object 2.
They're moving on a
frictionless, horizontal
surface.
And we're choosing as a
reference frame, the ground
frame.
Now, what we'd like to do
is identify two states.
So for our initial
state, we'll have--
if we're given some
initial conditions-- what
we'd like to do is represent
each object with a velocity
vector.
So here, we'll
write the 1 initial,
and let's suppose this object
is coming at it with the 2
initial as an example.
And once we've represented
the velocities of the objects,
we can write down their
momentum in the initial state.
Similarly, if these two objects
collide and they're moving,
we actually don't know which
way those objects will end up
moving.
And so what we'd again like
to do in our final state,
after this collision, is to
represent the velocities by,
again, vectors.
So this is V1 final
and this is V2 final.
And then, we can represent
the change in momentum.
So our momentum principle
now becomes-- in this case,
let's just assume that
the external force here
sums to zero-- we're
assuming no friction.
And then our momentum
principle says that 0
equals P final minus P initial.
And now, we can read
off those momentums
as vectors on the diagram,
and so what we have
is that the final
momentum will be
equal to the initial momentum.
So we can write down
M1 final plus M2
V2 final is equal to M1 V1
initial plus M2 V2 initial.
And that's how we can represent
a collision where there
is no external forces and
use our momentum principle
to get an vector equation.
Now, in many problems,
you're given information.
You might be given information
about the speeds and magnitudes
of the objects.
And in order to then
take this equation
and represent it in speeds and
directions or even components,
we need to choose some
coordinate system.
So if we choose a coordinate
system-- and that's
the third step-- so suppose
we choose a coordinate system,
then we can start to look at
two different representations
for our problem.
For instance, let's just choose
this to be the i hat direction.
Now, given that choice, we
could describe the velocities
in terms of components.
Now this gets awkward--
V1i x component i hat.
And similarly, we can write
down all the velocities-- V2i--
as V2ix i hat, et cetera,
for all the velocities.
And our momentum
equation in components
then becomes, in the i
hat direction, M1 V1ix
plus-- well, here we
have the final state,
so let's make this consistent--
the final plus M2 V2 final x
equals M1 V1 initial x
plus M2 V2 initial x.
And that's the same equation
that we have as vectors, now
expressed in terms
of components.
And recall that components
can be positive or negative.